[Music]
hi I'm Hannah I'm the world's okay his
mom and for the past three weeks I have
been trying three different pregnancy
workout routines I wanted to try a few
and see what was my favorite cuz I
actually do enjoy working out this
pregnancy it's something that keeps me
feeling energized it's time that I can
kind of Zen out to myself and I do
really enjoy it so I tried three
different workouts from three different
decades one from the early 1910s one
from the 1980s and one that's
recommended today now do not change your
workout routine if you're pregnant
unless you are being seen by a doctor
and you run it by your doctor first I'm
having a very healthy normal pregnancy
I'm communicating consistently with my
doctor through all of this so if you're
thinking of trying something from this
video or changing your workout routine
and you're pregnant please consult your
doctor before making any changes today
it's going to be one pre 1960's so from
the 1910s up until the 1960s sorry I'm
reading my research here the studies on
what they recommended for exercise are
kind of vague and kind of all over the
place but one of the exercises that they
recommended in the early 1910s was light
housework so I'm going to do that today
I'm getting into character
I'm cooking and this counts as exercise
which is kind of cool but it's also kind
of boring Pettaway it did you know core
work hurry on to the next row
[Music]
now I'm taking a quick rest because I'm
fragile
and I need rest and I actually kind of
like this it's a nice excuse to relax a
little bit
preparing for this baby gets very very
hectic you know when you're working full
time and I already have two kids I am
just always doing some things now we're
gonna try walking around my verdict for
today 1910s prenatal workout routine is
I actually enjoyed it a lot more than I
thought I would it's actually nice to
take it easy every once in a while I
think the level of activity is a little
low for me but I can understand why
somebody would want that or feel like
that's necessary for pregnant women
because it is really trying on the body
19 tens workout routines 80s week
oh hi we also have literature this is
the Jane Fonda pregnancy book and there
are some killer workouts in here and so
we're gonna suit up and get started on
our 80s workout
this is actually kind of hard look one
two and bend over and two ladies and
then out in binge what no you don't like
it anyway
no okay well that's it for our first day
of a DS workouts I feel like I actually
worked out ready
sweet let's do three one two pleasure on
it poor and we rest into this for a
little bit yeah our legs are trying to
push up energy
[Music]
I think your fake belly okay head
forward and best swing what could she do
it
meet bangs for this one
[Applause]
[Music]
do you think of the eighties tape
I don't you did a good job you're really
good at it
why how'd you feel about it you didn't
like it I'm so surprised I thought you
loved it so many lunges well I
personally thought that was fun I'm
excited to keep doing it I thought that
was great so I'm about to start my own
workout for this week I'm gonna be doing
the elliptical for 30 minutes I do it at
an 11:00 resistance out of 20 it goes
from zero to 20 resistance in the G one
mile forward and one mile backward I
usually get about two and a quarter
miles done in 30 minutes I don't go
super fast I think it's more important
for me to like to spend 30 minutes doing
it so I'm gonna do that and I'll be my
workout for this evening
six months end of the day baby do they
thing workout see you probably a mile
and a half in I'm bored that's the thing
with this Oh ten minutes left and I'm
like oh there's one watch TV I'm proud
of myself
truly the majority of the time spent
doing that exercise is just me sitting
on the floor trying to will myself to do
it because the thirty minutes goes by
quickly I get like bored and annoyed
well I'm doing it but then at the end I
feel really good she's like slow cardio
has been really good for me
but I probably do need to change things
up a little bit cuz it's kind of
repetitive i struggling with finding a
motive
to exercise this week and the boys so
kindly volunteered to do it with me so
that I feel a little bit more motivated
we're going to switch the neck we're
going to do a cardio a prenatal cardio
workout video Jack's new man leave us be
right
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
yeah I thought that that was okay the
workout was a little repetitive and I
didn't feel like I got much of a full
body workout
it was just a couple of my muscles like
over and over and over but it was really
fun doing it with why hate ten out of
ten would do together for why it was
doing it two out of ten would not do it
again if I was by myself would you do it
again yeah do fun with me
I'm doing it yeah I did one this morning
we are going to try prenatal yoga they
also call it yogalates but it's super
trendy right now everyone's doing it and
I see so many workout tapes on it so
we're gonna give it a try see how we
feel after and yeah just just gone with
an open mind especially when doing it
with kids we don't have yoga mats
because I am you know a fancy mom like
that so we put a towel down and I think
it's gonna be slippery
maybe oh I like this position this is
like putting pressure on my stomach
how was she doing it there's some
experiment
[Music]
and you go up get your leg up and you go
down oh yeah oh yeah okay that was fun
only because Wyatt did it with me and
kind of Jackson
so which exercise at the end of all this
was my favorite well it has become very
clear to me that prenatal exercise is
really just personal preference there's
not a one-size-fits-all workout routine
it will probably continue to do a
workout routine that's recommended today
but I didn't really enjoy the 80s
aerobics so I might make that a little
part of my routine maybe one day a week
or something now if you have any
questions about prenatal workouts or
pregnancy leave those in the comments or
you can message me on Instagram or if
you have any requests for a future
episode while I'm still pregnant leave
that in the comments as well
[Music]
yeah working out